what is terraform and how can it be used
to help you manage your infrastructure
and what is infrastructure as code and
how can it benefit the business
if you're asking yourself any of these
questions you're in the right place
terraform is an open source
infrastructure as code tool by hashicorp
for publishing resources including
Google Cloud Resources with declarative
configuration files
these files can be shared amongst team
members treated as code edited review
and even version
this enables you to build and deploy
complex Google Cloud infrastructure by
running a few simple commands
the getting started with terraform for
Google Cloud course
learn how to use terraform and
infrastructure as code tool to create
and manage your Google Cloud
infrastructure
hello my name is Rekha and I'm on we're
both course developers at Google Cloud
we want to welcome you to the getting
started with terraform for Google Cloud
course the purpose of this course is to
explore the terraform workflow in detail
you'll become familiar enough with the
terraform workflow that you know the
purpose of each phase and how it's
implemented this content is designed for
devops engineers Cloud Architects Cloud
engineers and anyone who's interested in
using terraform to create and manage
their Google Cloud infrastructure this
is a fundamental course that covers the
basics of terraform for Google Cloud
the prerequisite for this course is
Google Cloud fundamentals core
infrastructure
you'll also need to have basic
programming skills a familiarity with
using CLI in a general familiarity with
Google Cloud
[Music]
through a series of videos and Hands-On
Labs you will explore the business need
for terraform and infrastructure as code
and the benefits of using it in your
environment
you learn about terraform's features and
functionalities you'll also be equipped
to use terraform resource blocks
variables and output values to create
Google Cloud infrastructure resources
you'll also learn to use modules to
build reusable code
in addition you'll be equipped to
explain the terraform State file on its
importance
are you ready well let's get started